astronomy can be a fascinating field of
science but it can also easily seem
fanciful remote or even irrelevant when
faced with the many challenges of
day-to-day life here on Earth
it's quite common for my colleagues and
I to be asked why we study astronomy why
our research on the universe is
important or more pragmatically why it's
worth paying for
depending on who you ask answers might
range from the importance of scientific
education and literacy to the
inspirational power of space or even the
unexpected practical applications that
might one day grow out of pure research
it's clear that communicating the
discovery's importance and wonder of
astronomy to the rest of the world is a
crucial job for many of us
when asked to think of an expert science
Communicator someone who excels at
sharing the wonders of the cosmos and
the beauty of billions of stars with an
everyday audience Carl Sagan's name
often comes to mind
from the Cosmos TV series to his
award-winning books and other writings
Sagan is often seen as a leading figure
in the world of science communication
but he wasn't the first or the only
messenger for sharing the excitement of
space with the world
in this lesson we'll explore the many
things that have collectively sparked
our enthusiasm for astronomy and why
these are such a crucial part of the
research we do
when did you first become interested in
space
it no doubt happened before you sat down
to watch this lesson
maybe you learned about space in school
or read about it in a book or watched an
educational program on television
maybe you read comic books filled with
spaceships and aliens or devoured
science fiction novels or watched
episode after episode of Star Trek
maybe you simply noticed one night that
the sky looked beautiful or saw a story
on the news about adventurous astronauts
or some incredible new scientific
discovery
whichever path you took something likely
captured your imagination and made you
curious enough about space to want to
learn more
selling space can sometimes seem like an
easy task simply showing people the
wonders of the universe can be enough to
ignite their interest
while some may be lucky enough to live
under dark skies and be introduced to
astronomy through backyard stargazing
others may need a different view in
order to see the stars
the sight of the night sky is also only
the first step
questions ranging from what star is that
to how do the stars actually work mean
that a new astronomy Enthusiast will
want to hear from an expert
the first venues for sharing expert
knowledge of astronomy were museums and
in particular planetariums
depictions of the night sky date back to
indigenous art but the first record of a
moving depiction of the night sky comes
from the year 1229 when Holy Roman
Emperor Frederick II stole a tent built
by Arab Craftsmen during the Crusades
the tent could be spun and tiny holes
poked in its canopy would simulate the
night sky to a viewer sitting inside
during the day
producing what may have been the first
planetarium show
intricate mechanical models of the
constellations and solar system would
continue to be built for hundreds of
years with steadily improving accuracy
the first planetarium as we know them
today was built in the early 1900s as
part of the deutsches museum in Munich
the museum was imagined as a celebration
of science and engineering and today
it's still one of the largest Science
and Technology museums in the world
its founder Oscar Von Miller wanted to
feature astronomy in the museum but
struggled to figure out how to simulate
a night sky for the public
he eventually contacted the Carl Zeiss
Optical company to get their help in
constructing a public-friendly astronomy
show
their Engineers began by imagining a
ceiling poked full of holes just like
the Arab planetarium tent from hundreds
of years earlier
but the lighting involved for a large
viewing area seemed impossible
eventually they shifted to the idea of
using tiny light bulbs inside a large
ball-shaped room
but powering hundreds of light bulbs and
turning the ball and modeling both
slow-moving stars and faster moving
planets began to become unmanageable
it was Walter bowersfelt A Zeiss
engineer who would later become one of
the company's directors who got the idea
to use the Dome not as a light bulb
housing but as a screen projecting
images of stars and planets onto it from
a central mechanism that would be much
smaller and easier to control
the calculations and construction took
years and was slowed by World War One
but in 1923 the spectacular new Zeiss
planetarium technology had its first
debut at the company's Factory in yena
to great acclaim
professional astronomers were among its
first admirers
Ellis stromgren the director of the
Royal Copenhagen Observatory described
it as a school theater and Cinema in one
the success of the deutsches Museum
Planetarium sparked a Resurgence of
interest in astronomy and a flurry of
building projects as new planetariums
sprouted up all over the world
the Adler Planetarium in Chicago opened
in 1930 followed by the Griffith
Observatory planetarium in Los Angeles
and the Hayden planetarium in New York
City in 1935 all using Zeiss projector
technology
by the late 1940s there were more than
200 planetariums in the United States
alone and other companies were getting
into the business of building star
projectors
today some of the best and largest
planetariums are shifting to digital
projection and full Dome video
capabilities
some of these projections can now be
directly paired with enormous
astronomical data sets things like the
Sloan digital Sky survey that we
discussed in our last lesson or
multi-wavelength data from telescopes
like Hubble and Chandra
video domes can show specially produced
shows with cutting-edge special effects
that can transport visitors to the
surface of the Sun the edge of the
universe or the inside of a black hole
many others still rely on the classic
projection style first pioneered by
Walter bowersfeld pairing indoor views
of the night sky with live narration
provided by enthusiastic planetarium
employees or volunteers
there are more than 1 000 planetariums
in the United States hosting more than
20 million annual visitors
for nearly a century planetariums and
the museums that host them have been
invaluable tools for science
communication and Sharing The Riches of
the night sky with everyone
they can also make quite an impression
in the first few years after it opened
one of the many visitors to New York
City's Hayden planetarium was a young
Carl Sagan
in the middle of the 20th century a
television program on Space captured the
national imagination combining
cutting-edge special effects with a
knack for imagination and storytelling
it inspired viewers young and old to
ponder the mysteries of the universe I'm
talking of course about Star Trek
Star Trek premiered in 1966. it was the
product of Gene roddenberry's
imagination enthusiasm for space travel
sparked by the space race and a boatload
of Science Fiction influences
for decades many professional and
amateur astronomers have credited
fictional worlds or stories with first
inspiring their interest in the Stars
I grew up on ET and Star Wars and
devoured books like Carl Sagan's contact
science fiction that combined adventure
and storytelling with the gloriously
geeky details that I'd learned to love
today we refer to fancible stories about
adventures in space as science fiction
but stories of Adventures in the night
sky stretch back for centuries if not
Millennia and can be found in countless
indigenous histories
let's look at an example
one story of astronomy and exploration
imagines a newly created Universe with
its creator traveling across the land
and filling it with new people and
languages
this Creator carried a bunch of
languages with them and every time they
created a people they gave them a
language
when they got to the Western Ocean they
liked the land so much that they stayed
there filling it with people who spoke
all sorts of languages
this made communicating difficult and it
quickly caused a problem because the
Creator made a small design mistake they
built the sky too low
it was convenient at the time letting
people travel in and out of the sky at
will but it also meant tall people were
whacking their heads on it and it was
forever getting in the way
the people needed a solution but it was
tough because they spoke so many
different languages
eventually a huge Gathering was called
nearly everyone came and they all
managed to agree on a common word and
signal that would let them lift the sky
at the same time they lifted again and
again and slowly lifted the sky to where
it is today
the problem was that a few people missed
the meeting
this included three Hunters one of them
with his dog chasing four elk through
the forest the elk went running up into
the night sky and the hunters followed
them not realizing that while they were
up there everyone else was lifting the
sky until it was too high for them to
make it back down
this meant that the four elk were stuck
in the sky and so were the three Hunters
even the dog got stuck in the sky
sitting by his Hunter's side
the story tells us that they're still up
there today
in fact you've probably seen them
they make the constellation that we know
as the Big Dipper
this is a story from the Snohomish
people whose traditional lands are just
north of where I teach at the University
of Washington in Seattle
it's a fictional story but just like any
other good space adventure it imagines a
time when people could freely travel
into the heavens and makes listeners
look at the stars for a little longer
anyone hearing this Snohomish story
would immediately recognize the Big
Dipper afterward whenever they looked up
and most would probably make a
particular effort to look for the hunter
with his hard to spot dog
today a curious listener might
investigate further and learn that
they're named mizar and Alcor and that
there are actually six stars contained
in that apparent pair
Alcor is a binary star system and mizar
is a quadruple system
science fiction as we traditionally
think of it has always held a deep
fascination with space travel and Far
Away worlds
Jules Verne imagined a trip to the moon
in one of his books
Orson Welles made an indelible
impression on listeners with the radio
broadcast describing an alien invasion
and authors from Edgar Rice Burroughs to
Ray Bradbury to Andy Weir imagined The
Perils and Adventures of a Journey to
Mars
many of these science fiction authors
simply used space as a setting they may
use a dangerous planet or hostile aliens
as story elements but the details of
their books are less about the physics
of stars and galaxies and more about the
feelings imaginings and politics of the
people they feature
still for countless audiences especially
younger audiences these stories brought
their imaginations into space and fed
their curiosity about the wider universe
Star Trek was immensely influential in
this Arena
today astronomers who study the science
of life on other worlds remember an
episode from season one where the
Enterprise crew encounters silicon-based
life forms
this was a pretty good fictional premise
rooted in the shared Atomic properties
of silicon and carbon the atoms that
form the backbone of almost all
biological molecules found on Earth
Star Trek also offered early and
Progressive Role Models Lieutenant Uhura
is a favorite of many scientists today
who saw themselves in the brilliant
black professional woman who worked as
the cruise translator
a decade after Star Trek premiered
movies and television had decisively
joined books as key mediums for science
fiction
by the time Star Wars arrived on the
scene in 1977
space was a common setting for stories
Star Wars added its groundbreaking
special effects to the mix making space
come alive for people in a way it never
had before
still these visually spectacular mediums
were mainly being used to tell imagined
stories
space was a setting or a backdrop with
educational content left to classrooms
and textbooks or to planetariums
all of that would change just three
years after Star Wars was released with
the debut of a new and Innovative TV
show Cosmos
Carl Sagan was born in Brooklyn in 1934.
neither of his parents were scientists
but he nevertheless credited them both
with fostering his senses of Wonder and
skepticism at an early age
the Hayden planetarium fans the Flames
of Sagan's early interest in astronomy
and science fiction authors from H.G
Wells to Robert Heinlein caught his
imagination and strengthened his passion
for storytelling
still despite his enthusiasm it wasn't
until high school that Sagan learned
that astronomer was in fact a job and a
profession that paid well
once he learned that he was able to set
astronomy as his career goal
many other space enthusiasts including
myself have similar backgrounds it's one
thing to be caught up in the Grandeur
and excitement of the cosmos but quite
another to imagine devoting your life to
it when faced with the realities of
needing a steady paying job
Sagan earned his bachelor's Masters and
doctoral degrees from the University of
Chicago
studying under eminent planetary
scientist Gerard Kuiper
his early career resembled that of many
other young accomplished scientists he
was a researcher at the University of
California Berkeley and then a tenure
track professor at Harvard
Sagan however was denied tenure at
Harvard and criticized for an approach
to science that some believed was too
broad
as a planetary scientist his work ranged
from Radio observations of Venus to work
on the habitability of Jupiter and
Saturn's moons
Sagan's work also necessitated studying
biology Evolution and climate science an
unusual Approach at the time when
researchers tended to choose and stick
with a single specialty
most astronomers at the time didn't
Venture far outside their own field
Sagan moved from Harvard to Cornell in
1968 where he was encouraged to continue
his multi-disciplinary work and Foster
his growing interest in science
communication and popular writing
in 1977 he published the dragons of Eden
a book that explored the evolution of
intelligence
the book his debut Popular Science
publication won a Pulitzer Prize and in
the aftermath of this success he was
approached by PBS to write and star in a
science television series designed for a
general audience
Cosmos premiered in 1980 to both popular
and critical acclaim
Sagan's skill for writing and his clear
direct speaking style connected well
with audiences
the show also used the dazzling
cinematic special effects that had
delighted people in Star Wars to tell
not a fictional story but a real one
Sagan could wander through an
illustration of space-time or simulate
flying between planets and stars on an
imagined spaceship his journeys visually
resembled The Adventures of Star Trek or
Star Wars but now the story was our own
universe and the science of how it
worked
after The Sensational success of Cosmos
Carl Sagan went on to become the most
recognizable and well-known science
Communicator of all time
even in the midst of his success however
some colleagues still turned up their
noses at Sagan seeing him as a lesser
scientist because he was speaking to the
public instead of to his peers and
working on TV shows instead of research
papers
still his efforts made him a hero to
Young viewers who now saw astronomy and
science as a world they could inhabit
he also made a crucial impact on older
viewers who could now look at things
like the Hubble Space Telescope and
other taxpayer-funded endeavors and C
through Sagan's eyes the value they
offered
Sagan passed away in 1996 at the age of
62. but his legacy remains in the
immense surge of science communication
venues and professionals
planetariums and museums continue to
offer accessible introductions to the
science of astronomy entire television
channels now feature scientists that
share their excitement with a wide
audience including a number of
astronomers
Cosmos itself was rebooted in 2014. this
time hosted by Neil deGrasse Tyson
another new york-born astronomer who
corresponded with Carl Sagan as a teen
and eventually took up a post at the
Hayden planetarium as director
today popular science books regularly
become best sellers and span a vast
array of topics with the Advent of
social media Grassroots science Outreach
has popped up everywhere from YouTube to
Twitter
scientists record podcasts
teleconference with classrooms and join
video game streaming platforms for Q and
A's it's never been easier to hear from
professional scientists
sometimes we even write and record
lessons for the Great Courses
but why why should we treat science
communication as a heroic Endeavor in
astronomy are Carl Sagan's detractors
right should scientists stick to science
after all filming a TV show or sharing
Research on Twitter takes up time that
scientists could be spending on Research
if we think of science as merely the
cycle of making and testing hypotheses
this could be a fair argument but
science is more than that
it's also about sharing knowledge and
this makes science communication a
fundamental part of scientific research
and for a field like astronomy where the
importance of our work might not be
immediately clear communicating what we
do is vital
a society that funds research should be
encouraged to hear about the results and
to understand how these results fit into
the larger world
pure scientific research also always
offers the possibility of unexpected
scientific gains
think of general relativity a brilliant
but not terribly practical Theory when
it was first described in 1915.
and now think about how the smartphone
in your pocket or the navigation in your
car crucially depends on Einstein's
theories
I also like to think of astronomy as a
Gateway Science
we may not regularly invent new
technology or cure diseases but the
cosmos clearly captures people's
imaginations in a way that few other
things can
someone may read about black holes and
decide to study them
or they may ask questions about the
computers that simulate black holes and
become inspired to build a better
computer
or they may go into another field
entirely but still cherish the
importance of scientific inquiry
an enthusiasm for the Stars can easily
turn into an enthusiasm for other Realms
of Science and the more we can encourage
this the better
astronomers are often asked about the
Practical applications of our field
some of our answers are admittedly
pretty speculative general relativity
did great things for GPS but we're still
not quite clear on what gravitational
waves could do for everyday technology
here on Earth
that said there is one pretty immediate
and practical reason for citizens of our
planet to want to keep an eye on Space
once in a while space comes to us
in our next lesson we'll begin exploring
our immediate Cosmic backyard and talk
about some of our closest neighbors who
sometimes get a bit too close for
comfort